it looks like adele and rich paul are
still going strong absolutely yay the
rumored couple stepped out earlier this
week for a dinner date at la restaurant
odium that's a 33 year old british
singer looking school girl chic in a
black turtleneck a pink plaid miniskirt
and black heeled boots while the 39 year
old sports agent goes casual in a black
velour hoodie jeans and blue sneakers it
looks really amazing an eyewitness tells
et the two kept a low profile by exiting
the restaurant through the kitchen door
adele and rich are rumored to be dating
but of course the grammy winner hasn't
confirmed a thing given she's super
private yeah very but we do know this
the pair has been spending a whole lot
of time together this summer
back in july they were spotted at game
five of the nba finals at footprint
center in phoenix arizona speaking of
singing beautiful voice of adele an
eyewitness at the time told et quote
they had their eyes on each other almost
as much as they did on the game adding
that there wasn't any overt pda between
the two but quote they were laughing and
cheering and having a great time they
seemed very happy and over the weekend
the two reportedly attended lebron
james's wife savannah's birthday party
in west hollywood
[Music]
that's adele vibin to [ __ ] at the bash
hair flipping to cardi b and megan the
stallion's hit song now from the top
make it drop that's some wet and cushy
absolutely incredible yeah the instagram
video is only about 2.5 seconds of adele
but it's clear she's living her best
life
[Music]
of course fans have been waiting for the
33 year old singer's highly anticipated
new album which she addressed when she
hosted saturday night live last fall my
album's not finished rumor has it pun
intended the album is coming later this
year and get this adele's close friend
british comedian alan carr revealed to
gracia uk he's actually heard some
tracks from the new album calling the
songs he listened to quote so amazing
[Music]
and while we might have to wait a little
bit longer for adele's new music we are
living for her rare public outings
[Music]
you